do you think
AI in order to become super intelligent
in AGI should have a body
it depends on on what the goal is I
think that there's this assumption
in that question that
intelligence intelligence should be kind
of person-like whereas you know as we
were just talking about
um you can have these greater than
single human intelligent organisms like
the stock market which obviously do not
have bodies and do not speak a language
right and like you know and and just
kind of have their own
system
um but
so I don't know my guess is
um there will be limits to what
A system that is purely an intelligence
can understand about the Human Condition
without having the same not just senses
but like
our bodies change as we get older right
and and we kind of evolve and
I think that those very subtle
physical changes
just drive a lot of social patterns and
behavior around like when you choose to
have kids right like just like all these
you know that's not even subtle that's a
major one right but like
um you know how you design things around
the house
um so yeah I mean I think I think it
would if the goal is to understand
people as much as possible I think I
think that that's
trying to model those Sensations is
probably somewhat important but I think
there's a lot of value that can be
created by having intelligence even that
that is that is separate from that it's
a separate thing